From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is Emilye Crosby on December 3rd, 2015 with Nathaniel "Nate" Hawthorne Jones in his home in Claiborne County on his land, land where he was born.
And we're here with the Civil Rights History Project, which is co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
And John Bishop and Guha Shankar are also here with us this morning. Mr. Jones, thank you so much for doing the interview with us.
Can you start by telling us when and where you were born?
I'm a-born. It was 1914.". Right here in this community, right here where we are now. Just a quarter mile east of the poor, we are now.
At that time, your family didn't own the land then, did they?
No, they moved in here from Lorman, Mississippi.
And I was a first child, born back here. All the rest of them, if it was three of us, out of ten, born back here.
You know, I was a first one, born back here in 1914 in Papakain, in from already left Lorman, Mississippi, came over here.
And for people who aren't doing the math through a quick how old are you today?
I'm 101 and I'm able to [live/make it to] 17 next year, be 102.
So can you tell us about your family and growing up right here in this community?
My family grew up right here in this area. We were farmer and public came in here as a shelter. That was our occupation.
And my mama, she passed on, when five years I started to born. And my stroke mother's three here in this house.
This house still belonged to a building in 1800. But anyway, this was my stroke mother's day.
My mother passed on, you know, Papa had, we, Papa had all those children she left.
And the stepmother had five children. And somehow he married my stepmother because she lived here in this house.
The house that really lived in, you know, it eventually burned down.
But that's the way it was. As my mother died, I was five years old, he married.
And, you know, that made 15 years, yes, she had five. And my mother left 10.
And I don't know how to raise them in a children, but I wanted some day. But I knew we all had something, you know, a job to do.
What was your choice?
To get the care, it was going and putting up the cares every day, you know.
You had to pay for the cares. Kyle would go in the parents' house. I would always take care of the cares.
You know, while I was old enough to do it, yes.
What was your school like?
Well, we had two schools. We were on the Facebook, we had a bunch of national and we had B-Slam.
We were only, you know, we were only having, we were able to get six months schooling.
That's all we had, six months.
Until we, from time and time, school was six years, six years, over 11 or so, school.
And until, you know, until, they got about nine years old, you know.
I didn't ever get, you know, my six months schooling. You had to go to field at that time, we shared trouble.
And we had to, you know, go to field and we had to keep, you know, landlord, that's the good day.
Quite the good. For that one-po, you know, share. You had to be in the field. You had to keep the trouble.
And we, if we got, after I got nine years old, if I got six months schooling, you know, I never get six months schooling after I got nine,
but you know, started schooling. Six months started. The school was six months.
I got six months schooling until I got about nine years old, giving up to go to field.
After that, you know, if it is the rain or anything like that, we could go to school.
That's the way it was. We back.
So, did you hope for the rainy days? Did you hope for the rainy days?
Yeah, it was quite natural. And we hope for the rainy days.
And there was so, and it was so bad of bad, you know, sometimes rain, you know, more than one day.
And then we caught over the creek. That cross-creek goes school.
And we caught over the creek and rain. And the creek got up. We had to walk all the way around five miles and get back home.
But, you know, it's been seeing hard and no day.
It was a jar just to get to go to school and get out of that field and go to school and then.
But anyway, after you got a certain age, you never get that six months schooling.
But we was, well, had good instructor, good teacher would call them and over there.
And my little sister Emma, you know, she got full six months, you know, except, you know, the rain and everything.
She would bring out a assignment back from school every day.
When a rain would go to school, we would write assignments, send it back.
When a rain would go to school, you know, sometimes be eight or ten of them on the class.
And those children were fortunate enough to go to school. You see, they were at top of the class.
And most time, I started at the foot of the class being eight or ten in the middle of the class.
And for that day, I would be at a head.
Because I'd been, the teacher would send my assignment back by my sister, the little baby sister.
And I would study my assignment.
What did you have to do to move from the back of the class to the front?
Well, it was, it was, it was, it had two, two circuits.
There was arithmetic and spelling.
On arithmetic, you know, he had to go to the board and then each child go to the board.
The teacher could put up a sign.
And if he couldn't work that problem, you know, that he would wipe it out and then put it up there for me.
But I would be the last one, you know, and go there and work that problem.
Yeah, sometimes the mother's, the baby and sometimes, you know, I would have a,
a long, they put a problem, I come real nine, they put that problem until I work.
But sometimes I could iron around 80 to 10 within a class.
Then I'd be at top, on top, let's go for a leader.
But soon to fail, I had to go back to the video.
We were, well, she had a problem.
If you had owned your own land, would you have been able to go to school further?
Yeah, if we had, well, I think two family there, the teacher had his own land.
He had two children and one of them was in my class.
And it was two family in that head, head down.
Don't show them when the school is every day. They got that sick month school.
But no, she had trouble, we just didn't get it.
I think he told me once that because you didn't go the full time that you had to repeat a grade?
Yeah, sometimes I had to repeat, but most times he was sent my assignment by my baby sister.
And that's why I could keep up.
But a lot of, you know, still like I always wanted to go to school.
But you know, just what happened, it was molded.
And I was 15 of them.
Well, it was just impossible, you know.
It was still in the land, you know, you had to produce something.
We had to have cotton and corn and peas.
Three things that we had to raise to, and they would get one post or everything.
One post or cotton, one post or corn, one post or peas.
We were after we, my dad had moved from here.
My dad had my, my, stuck mother here as a mom and dad.
And we had a big house by around on the, just the same land, the Cunburts of land.
And my dad already moved out of here.
And all these four rooms, when we were on farming, we were filling up with peas.
When we laid by our corn, we were planting peas.
The peas run up on the corn, you know.
And then when we, in the fall of the year, we had picked up peas, I think I said,
one four to peas.
Sometimes 75, 80 or 100, we were, we had to pick that much peas.
And I could, I could grab 100 and some pound of peas over them, corn, peas and corn,
you plant peas and peas grew up on the corn and just hang it over our, you know.
That's why they charged so much, you know, yet they paid one fourth of peas.
If you made two or three hundred bushes, you didn't get better full service.
Well, I mean, the landowner got a pose.
Landowner got a pose of everything, corn, cotton, everything, you know.
That's why we known as shear hold on.
We're going to say some people, you know, have a half and half and if you were given a fourth, don't they?
Yeah, we had our own, we had our own horses and nears.
And if the landowner, you know, had the funnest of horses and nears of things, all the equipment,
that's why we did have to work on the head.
Bring you worked on a fourth, we had our own team.
We're kind of, we're pretty close to all corn here.
Did you ever go to campus when you were a young man?
I went to, I didn't go, I went over to campus with regular because I had any sleep over there.
But anyway, we went to commemoration.
We would go to, that's always, you know, head and mind, I wish I were able to go to the old corn cart.
But we would go there every time they would have some, and they had a, first was baseball.
We used to go to see them play baseball.
You know, they were just like, real, but they were all going to have the best team in the South at that time.
So we used to go there when we were kids, and go to every commemoration.
We were always wanting to go to all commemoration.
But when I was in a state of great, you know, I had to go to the wood, I had to go log in.
I was unfortunate to go to college at that time.
You told me one time that when you were out on campus for one of the commensments,
you met somebody selling the Pittsburgh Courier?
Yeah.
I can't kind of remember, but I kept, I always, you know, taking the paper after then,
you know, paper occurred, I kept it for years after that.
And when you sent it to me when I was in service every year.
So do you remember why you wanted to have the Courier?
Why you wanted the paper?
Yeah, I wanted to keep up with it.
I always wanted, you know, baseball, play, or else, I was going to have one of the best baseball team at that time.
I would be a fourth of a man and you would talk to him and left hand picture.
He went from all comm to Chicago grade.
You see, he was a baseball and I know from all commemoration up in Big League.
And I used to watch him play all the time.
I always wanted to be a baseball pitcher, like be a boxer.
You were a pretty good player, you know?
I turned out to be a good player.
You know, I put it on a lot of games.
And also when I was in service after the war.
And I oversee, I played a lot of games, I beat a lot of team over there.
I didn't know you played in the service?
Yeah, I played over there after the war.
So can you tell me how you found out about the NAACP?
Yeah, I found out that by...
I was telling about I went to school at Egypt, that was first school, I went to.
And that same school we did here, there was a new church on that in the same...
We had a school in the church house, that was church, the Egypt recording.
And the preacher there was Reverend Martin, called Reverend Martin.
His wife was a teacher, and he was a minister.
And I used to go over there to the Sunday school and church home.
I played there for almost a second Sunday.
And somehow after I got drunk, I couldn't let that school come out of the Bishops' school here.
And I was just trying to thank for the age I was at that time.
He was a Reverend Martin, where the preacher, he was a minister of each church at that time.
And he worked on the ground, on the civil right.
He won, he couldn't be out on when I got a say, age 18.
I wasn't going to school there at the end, but I would go to church, I would go to church home to meet him.
And he won, he won't come in to do that into the civil right.
But anyway, it couldn't be known, we were always before becoming a member at the middle of Saturday afternoon.
And it was never been co-gistered.
And it would make sure that it wasn't better for you as a mayor.
Was this after the war?
Was this after World War II?
Before, wherever, World War II.
This was the fourth war, this war I went through, were all enough to go.
I was a breeze, I was trying to think that age.
I got a record of it, that age I was, when I come in bar with civil right, you just take the paper known as Gritz, I believe at that time.
And they had a lot of, in that bar, the civil right.
And that's when I got in touch with a friend of mine, he was somehow connected, his family connected with Rob Martin.
And I told them how I could have been a member.
And that's how he told me that he didn't take the underground".
We called it underground.
But anyway, we couldn't let it be known, if we meet.
We had to meet, you know, when placed in poultry in the church, the method of church, right call from him and him.
See that old church, right?
That's what we met.
And you had to be on the side of that afternoon.
And at that time, everybody was going to town and the wagon, everything.
It took him straight up there, be that fool.
And I was the friend of mine, he was a Mr. Charlie Cook, we call it.
He was related to Rob Martin.
And that's what he wanted to tell me, you take me down and I could die.
And I love it, I was trying to think, what did you have?
I think it might have been 1952.
I got the charter members out in 1952.
But anyway, that's what we used to meet on.
And finally, you know, something finally, it's got out, you know, I don't know how I would.
But it got out there with me, then, and we had to.
And that's the last time I had been like that.
But I went on a giant then, but you know, I had to keep my card in.
And if you then, you know, if you were caught with a car like that, you know, what would happen?
But some of the friends, you know, lost the card.
And that time, it was, the crew of Clang was around at that time too.
You couldn't let it be known that you, you was a member.
Were you afraid to join? Did you have any fear about it?
No, I never did have any fear.
I don't know what I don't remember here, sounds like that.
And I just wanted to be.
Yeah, I wanted to be a hood talk about, you know, freedom.
I heard talk about freedom.
You know, if you got enough freedom, you could cross the Mason-Dixon Line.
I heard all of that, I heard all of that at that time.
And I always liked to study a lot when I was young.
I wasn't able to go to school, but I could read.
And I would subscribe for the grit and the papers, you know, would talk about it.
So, then I would say, P.
How did you give them to the service, the military?
Were you drafted?
I was drafted.
I was drafted into the Navy.
From Camp Shelby.
You know, I went to Camp Shelby, you know, me and Lister, but I was really drafted.
Somehow I was there, and Jackson, and then he drafted.
And then he sent me and I was drafted into the service of the 1944, I believe.
That sounds right.
Yeah.
What was that experience like?
Well, that was, you know, it was the wonderful experience.
And I got in, you know, in the bootcamp.
It was just feel, of course.
You would then bring me a medal, not too far.
Or you're sometime in the Saipan, that's the only time I would get scared.
But anyway, you know, I think it was five.
I think it was, you know, a family of course, and then you know, the ship was out of the
center of Eagle.
Never stayed there a great while, a long time.
And the ship was out of there to Hawaii.
I'm seeing Hawaii, about three weeks in the ship, and I went out to the Majuro.
So, here it was a long time, I went by a ship, and I arrived at the aircraft, there it was.
And that's where they carried us.
But then Hawaii, that's where we got separated.
I think we were hunting some of us, left Bainbridge together.
And I meant to say, left from San Diego together.
And the first ship was making island.
That was the first ship we were on.
And then we had a spacecraft there, and full out playing on top.
And I was seeing Hawaii three weeks.
And when we left Hawaii, we left on the aircraft carrier.
I was playing on out to the wood at Hanwoven.
The wood was going on in Saipan when we got to Majuro.
And the thing was that, oh, 500 miles different.
But of course, the ice base was there on the jurors, new flying from there,
and brawmen in Saipan.
It was coming back.
And remember one, so you came back to Kia.
And remember that, well, anything to do the air base.
Because before I thought, you put me into my assignment
who was cooking and stood, I was a steward made before the North Star
cooking.
And I had to get a certificate, you know, from Washington DC's
to the east.
I was going to be a cook.
I got my certificate.
But anyway, all of the air base, and that's on time,
if we had an air raid, if we had ship raid, you know,
we send the Ato, we send, well,
many times we had to run out in the lagoon.
We couldn't get in for a whole, you know.
But we had to go out in the lagoon and up to the water in my neck.
Up to my neck, yeah.
We go there for a call.
They say, ship, prop heaters, one of those ship come over and think
a little while.
And we had those air raid and ship raid, too.
The thing was, I had to go in the ocean three times.
I remember three times I had the whole group of the group in the lagoon.
That's instilled digging for all folks.
We used to go out in the water until we got to the way.
Did you tell me once that you were part of a protest when you were in the Navy?
Part of that you had a protest while you were in the Navy?
I was in Hawaii.
Before, yeah, I was in the Navy, we had a hunger strike.
What was the hunger strike about?
They didn't want to feed up with the officer.
See, we was off as a cook.
We went forward to eat with the officer.
We didn't forward in in John the Mayor.
And you say, we, who is the...
That group, or no, is still made and still it.
So those are all African Americans?
Yeah.
Did the hunger strike work?
Yeah, it worked.
It worked for three days.
It was just hunger strike for three days.
It worked.
So you were able to eat in the...
Yeah, I'm gonna look at that.
These ships arrived.
I think it was a hunger strike.
I'm gonna look at that.
The group was 29 of...
I had the hunger strike.
29 of us went down to a...
We knew it was Joe and Majuro.
It was a long way.
It was...
It had taken us there for five days.
You get there, cold, and you know...
In the night in the day line,
you're taking us so long to get to the end of the day line.
You're going to go on night
and you're left there
and take so many days to get them out there
in the Maggiore in Majuro.
They're right near Australia.
Did you think it all about voting
while you were in the service?
Well, I voted for I was in the service,
but they said it back.
You know they probably threw it in the strike fight.
That was...
Yeah.
What about the poll tax?
Well, I had paid poll tax for I left.
I grew up for I left when I was in service.
I got 21 years old,
I had paid poll tax.
No.
That was for I went in service
and I thought God, you know,
it had paid me change.
I didn't have a...
You know, I got out of it
when I tried to get the vote, you know,
the edge of the vote.
Yes.
At a hard time, we were getting that done.
What would happen when you would try to...
When you were trying to register the vote,
was anybody doing that with you
or were you doing it by yourself?
In the three of us,
in the three of us trying,
we're not trying.
They would give us a...
I'm trying to think
with some part of the Constitution, you know.
They had that little book
to get where to go.
You told me that they gave you a copy
of the part of the Mississippi Constitution.
Yeah, that's the Mississippi Constitution.
You know, I ain't...
The sharpest I've ever really read back.
But anyway, to give you a copy of that,
and then, you leave this,
you give it that and you...
She's telling you,
you have to write down a copy of it,
and then write down the copy of it,
and then write down the copy of it.
And you have to sit up there
and try to think,
you know, I'm old now.
I can't remember that Constitution looked like it was...
Well, I can remember we're back,
we were the vote,
but anyway, I wrote it down and got everything straight.
I was the last one.
The leave I was,
and then I got the ball and...
Mr. Griffin?
Mr. Griffin.
Mr. Ellis Collins.
Ellis, he had a learning.
Griffin and I didn't have a learning.
I'd say, age, grade, learning.
And then Griffin, the sixth grade, I believe, was.
But anyway, Mr. Collins,
he went on,
got through four in the body,
and then he went down.
And I was left one in there,
and I'd come by,
and then he used to put mine down.
I didn't know what she had done to the collagen,
but she looked over mine,
and everything,
she said, well,
you didn't make it this time.
You made your neck doing necktie,
and she just wrote,
bought on there,
and she'd come back doing it again.
And then she took her second time,
and then she'd still didn't pass.
Then passed,
and then you were in a sod,
or you were giving her a little test,
and that's time I passed.
Passed.
What made the three of you decide to try to register
when nobody else was doing it?
Well, you know, I had,
got kind of,
learned a lot about that,
and then, you know,
the officers,
over there in the service,
were my officer,
he kind of,
I don't know where he from,
some part of the know about anyway,
he won't,
he always encouraged us,
you know, we all, we had up.
We should,
both, I voted for him,
and I went over there,
and sent it back.
They said,
they didn't do nothing but boarded,
but anyway,
he had good officers,
and he said,
I ought to vote,
and I went on,
and said,
my mate,
with me,
he, from Pogilman,
said,
then I do know my daughter in Trashville,
and I said,
what am I going to do?
Vote.
And all of the,
and he,
he encouraged us to,
we don't vote,
so that would have,
but not,
I had to do it all over,
we know God is out of the service.
Were you afraid,
when you were trying to register,
were you afraid anything
would happen to you or your family?
No, I wasn't afraid,
you know,
you know, the thing was going to have my,
and I don't know why,
I was never afraid,
I always wanted,
you know,
the vote called,
I used to get them papers,
and I said,
the people occurred
and the other people
read it all,
where other people
were voting,
and what happened,
up there in the north,
but anyway,
I always wanted the vote.
You told me one time
that when Reverend Smith
was running for Congress,
that you had somebody to come
and do a class on the Constitution,
and voter registration,
do you remember that?
I remember,
yeah, I'm saying it's a rubber.
When Reverend Smith,
a R.L.T. Smith,
when he was running for Congress,
he said that there was a young man
that came through
and did some voter registration classes,
do you remember that?
Oh yeah, yeah.
I remember that well as anything,
because, you know,
I don't know,
they would,
the police and everything,
be done style,
it was building there,
and poor gifting there,
we would be up style,
taking them tests and everything.
And when we come down,
the police would be done,
and what broke that beating up,
you know,
the most of them got scared, you know.
I wasn't so scared,
because, you know,
I said all the time,
it must've been where I was there,
even to go to the service,
the state and service,
you know, the two years
and half of the state and service.
I wasn't scared,
but anyway,
when we came,
when that class came,
when we came from up style,
all the police and,
was out there waiting on us.
You know, they wouldn't do anything to it,
but you know,
the other boys
that were meeting,
you know,
that's kind of made them scared,
and that broke that beating up,
you know,
but we had several meetings,
we tried to have
civil rights,
with the civil rights group,
you know,
first of all,
we were trying to get rid of the vote,
and that was part of it too, you know.
You know,
you know, rights and everything,
but anyway.
Do you remember that young man's name?
That came?
Hmm.
I,
I never see what that boy name.
Hmm.
I,
my memory,
good,
and youth, I believe,
but he,
from New York,
he's,
uh,
what are you on?
It's all of it.
Uh,
it was, uh,
Bob Moses.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was Moses.
Yeah.
I remember you said,
the first meeting,
you came downstairs,
and they started calling out the names,
and then, uh,
the next meeting,
it was only three of you that came.
Yeah, it was only three of you,
the other calling,
and riffing and all.
Um,
um,
and you, uh,
oh, you know what,
um, tell us about how you met Ms. Jones,
and you all getting married.
Well, um,
please admit,
uh,
I live around,
oh yeah,
even if we were,
she lived at that time,
when she,
she was young,
but young,
but she,
lived by,
she was young with me,
and, uh,
my brother stayed in the house
right down the lower hill,
and he,
he had married,
and, uh,
he had,
but, uh,
his wife had,
their first child.
And my,
uh,
wife,
she stayed right across the creek from,
you know,
that house,
right,
just a little disdined,
this way,
and the creek was on cross,
yeah, that was,
um,
my wife was,
you know,
staying over there with her,
and,
uncle,
come over visit uncle,
she, come over visit uncle,
and my,
brother,
and we were married then,
and they had,
they,
they put a child,
and,
my wife,
sister,
and my wife,
and,
the child,
while the other
were going to feel,
my wife was too,
young, you know,
to do that kind,
because she'd fight you,
young,
and name my wife,
you know?
She,
we stayed right around,
you know,
and they used to walk from,
right, right over there,
on,
over that,
I have,
you know,
my father,
and for the baby,
and,
she was just a little,
a girl,
and,
but,
you know,
I had never seen her before,
but,
her sister was known,
and my,
little nephew,
and,
but she would come,
over with her sister,
and,
we,
had come around to,
I have,
you know, to get milk or supply for the baby.
And there's a way I could try to cut them off.
I always try to get it.
I would see if there was a good little girl.
I wouldn't try to get close enough to see
or get acquainted with her anything.
But they could look through the woods
and see me trying to cut them off.
But they were wrong.
And I never, when I first got to know her,
she was a baby sitting for my brother.
No, she was just kidding.
I mean, she must have been around nine years old, of course.
I was near the fire.
I was a man.
Now, when she was 18, I was 22.
But man, that's the way it was.
But anyway, the distant number of deaths,
I got acquainted with her early.
Maybe before she used to run, try to cut off,
to coat them and cut off, because I was running.
That was right in here.
How long were you married before she passed away?
Seven, two years.
And how did you and Miss Jones,
you said when you first were on this land,
it was a sharecropping.
How did you come to buy this land?
Well, when I was in the service,
I sent, you know, she had allowance,
a filter, no paper, I'd all done,
with the rubber paint, and after I got my rate,
I was getting $109 a month.
And I sent all of that back.
I was sending my check back, even more.
And she kept that month, we had planned,
you know, when I got in service,
I wrote her every day.
She was right, me back every day, sometimes.
Sometimes, you know, the mayor gets delayed,
sometimes I would get $13, little, you know,
it'd be delayed.
But anyway, we made that suggestion
that we were gone, save all we could get in by land.
That's what started.
When we were young, when I was in the service,
and she saved my payday.
I was sending $100.
I was getting $9 after I got my rate.
And I sent that $100 back, in a month.
And she put it in the bank.
And she used her, and she just used her money.
She would get that $65 being a month.
But we wrote one another every day.
We took her out of the plan.
What we were going to do with that money,
that I was saving from the Navy.
So when you came back, you already were buying it?
Yeah, I never will forget, you know,
there's $16,000.
It was in the bank, I never would get.
But we bought the land 126, that,
eager from Conborough.
I miss it.
126, eager was, I believe,
somehow like $1400, something like that.
That's what you'd charge.
It looked like the Meehaw's paying $60.
I don't know, he was the four out of $60.
But anyway, that's the way we come back to 126,
eager was bought when I got out of the sew.
Did it, when you were registering the vote,
did it make a difference that you owned your own land?
I don't think, I don't think land had anything to do with it.
Of course, there were two or three people around here
at my professor's wife, and he owned in land,
but first of all, Britain and he owned it.
There were probably a few black owned in land,
owned it on land.
And somehow they would let them the vote.
I remember, you know, Mr.
because of the white comes from us of Britain and,
I remember, in Rev. Maw and,
and I could name around 18 people they let vote,
but they all were kinda higher up,
we're calling them, they had land,
the order they owned something.
Well now you remember what I'm not in the shop
is how I've been there, in 101 years old,
Oh, and sound pretty sharp, God.
Well, you know, he could run circles around us all.
You said that, so when did the movement get to,
how did it get to picking up around this area?
Moona is gotten picking up by, you know, Mr. Child,
everyone, the child ever come in here.
We were scared to do anything.
The child ever in the room to cheer when they came in here.
And they did everything they could, you know,
never was a bar racial attempt.
And they did everything, they grouped everything they could.
They came from coming and it was in nature, you know, we heard.
The first thing the new guy that is in nature is coming up
and they came up to feed.
And the white decide they have a bar racial committee.
And they picked the group that they want to meet with, you know,
that bar racial group.
And that was preachers and teachers,
which you know they were scared, scared of their jobs.
But anyway, they pick who they want to meet with,
try to prevent,
but still, you know, they were marching on this way,
they had come to feed.
And finally, they did come on the program,
and they came to give everything they could.
You said that the white got the bar racial committee
to try to stop the movement from coming.
Yeah, from coming.
How come they weren't successful?
Well, we kind of, we build against that group, of course.
We want, you know, we want to be free.
We want to be able to march and protest
about freedom.
We wanted to write, nevermind.
And so we decided they came on in the end of the way.
You know, really she, you know, forget the other fellow's name,
but anyway, Charles Evers.
Steve Marseaux.
Oh, he is.
Yeah, for me, from that, from the hundredth, that's right.
But anyway, that's when we got started.
Can you tell us what Rudy Shields was like?
Yeah, Rudy Shields was a brilliant, brilliant, brilliant,
brilliant fellow in Rio Bacinian.
Yeah, Rudy Shields was grew around and then pushed.
It was, you know, encouraged him to go out and try to get people
to reach the vote.
That's what that was.
That he was breathing by that, you know.
There's a lot of plantation you couldn't grow on.
And that was the most of the voters' role, you know, on plantation.
And you know, really she is trying to think the boy,
he just passed on, you know, what we really see is through.
George Henry Walker.
And the good from trying to gust the.
We're going to see her live today.
Yeah, yeah.
But anyways, those who want to know what right with Rudy Shields
to get the people to reach the vote, of course,
I worked on that group too.
Most of them who have scared to go on an all-con campus,
and the other one who went down and ran for so many children
to be voted, you know, to reach the vote in publicism.
But anyway, I worked with that group too.
And, uh...
What was Ms. Leesco Guster like?
Ms. Leesco Guster.
Yeah.
Oh, she just went with Rudy Shields,
and she did most of what was Rudy Shields,
Ms. Leesco Guster Walker.
Yeah.
Going to.
What, uh...
When the movement started, I know that the end of LACP needed some officers, right?
Mm-hmm.
And you agreed to do that.
How do the neighbors respond to people living out here when you decided to do that?
Well, they kind of like went along with me,
because if they hadn't went along with me, I couldn't have been successful at all.
Most knew, they most had confidence in me.
I don't know why, but they did.
And I don't know why.
You know, the white was on my side some kind of way.
I don't know if it was just by nature, who it was, but they did a lot,
and it helped me out a lot, especially in those days was hard.
It was a secret.
And you were schooled sometime?
Yeah.
Was this named Robert Seeders?
Okay.
And he was a friend of mine.
Did he come with you?
Yeah, he came out here and said, right in this house,
he said, right at that table, they'd go out there and cheer him maybe to 10 schools.
Yeah.
And he hired, sitting right in there, he hired my wife to know the working school system.
And he hired me, right in that room, right there in that room, right there.
He hired me to drive a school bus.
Yeah.
But he was a periscruist who was down there.
But anyway, he loved the hunt.
And he could run on my place and a lot of schools on this place were not up there on his place.
But anyway, he'd come down here and kill him.
I even had 10 schools.
He'd sit on that and drink coffee and eat right there, that's too great.
And they hired me, right?
He'd right in there and hired my wife in this right in that room, right there.
So, see.
If you don't look like it, but I said, I've got my first job driving a school bus, right?
So you were farm and and driving the school bus?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
At the same time, I'd get up.
And that's what was your friend and me.
You know, I counted him out of the real friend.
Well, I would get up and make my room and I could bring the book back here.
And then bring it in here because it was too long to get in here at that time, the road
and fix.
Like, you know, I lived at that house up there, you know, up there, a brown room.
And I would get a truck going back to the farm.
And they'd put a three or four hours on the farm.
And then you had to get in the truck and go back.
And then you had no wife, too, no wife thought she's a school.
Did she teach at the Russell School?
Yes, she taught.
That's why.
Did she switch to over to...
Poor Giftson.
Oh.
Well, all of the whites weren't...
Not all of the whites reacted the same way, right?
Did you have any trouble?
No, I didn't have any trouble.
And somehow I had worked with white pretty much everything I got grown in the...
the Somials and different things.
And I will have known by being a Tamikura, you know.
Everybody went high and you know, being my brother, who worked together.
And that's really...
I guess that's really...
I was successful.
A nurse called...
I didn't work with no...
I was...
But all of the brothers I had, you know, were one of the two...
One were the same age, my stepbrother.
And we worked together.
We locked together, locked only longer together.
So...
Was that Eddie Duffin?
Yeah.
Eddie Duffin?
You remember him, yeah.
Yeah, me and him were the same age.
But Kellev was the little older, most of the time I worked with the older one.
And I did the one my age.
But anyway, that's how it was.
Everybody wanted to hire us, you know.
We didn't have to even think about wanting a job, a job on us.
Yeah.
You're a good worker.
What did Mr. Ellis say to you once you joined the...
When the movement got started?
Remember Mr. Eli Ellis?
Oh yeah.
He told me he said, well...
They...
You heard that you...
You joined a thing, nobody called it.
And he said, now we've been good to you.
And we let you have anything that you want.
Money here at the bank.
As a year, Mr. Ellis, I've been good to you all.
I paid my bills.
He...
He paid all the alone dies.
He bought our lives and you're right.
You're right.
But anyway, that's...
That was...
But he's dying by then.
He was the vice president.
But he had been right down your hunt with me.
That's really...
You know, he was there and he had been so good to me.
I had been good to him because he'd come down on hunt.
On my place in...
And hunt everywhere, I'd be with him, hunting.
And he killed...
He's...
Paul the alone died.
But I later...
You're right, right.
But anyway, I had a lot of friends, you know.
A lot of white friends.
The sent-john was the same way.
But I mean, he was my boy name.
But he didn't think nobody...
Could've been any lower than Nick, his brother.
Who was that?
The sent-john.
You remember in the sent-john?
Mm-hmm.
You know, the last one, we're kind of...
Get a laminate in the...
Light plays.
Robert sent-john.
Oh, yeah, I think I did those.
I remember, rather than that.
Herding name.
Yeah.
What about Reverend Spencer?
Was he the head of the Human Relations Committee?
Was he on the BIRacial Committee?
Yeah, Reverend Spencer.
He was on the BIRacial Committee.
He was in a group, the scary group.
He didn't thank you.
It was time.
He just wasn't time.
We make all the protests that the group were making.
We were all retorting.
This is just on this way, there's too long time.
Time, no, we don't know.
It's the time.
Right now, it's the time that we were done.
And he came before he, you know, God disabled.
He changed.
He made a change.
What did he say to you when you were...
You told me once that some of your...
Some of the people, some of the farmers you knew,
didn't think you ought to go public with the NAACP
and tried to talk you out of that.
Yeah, they tried...
Many, many of them tried to talk me out.
But, you know, I just didn't have a change because...
Most of them had never been inducted in the service.
They had never been...
You know, with other people that had been free all their lives.
But anyway, I was doing everything I could.
I had wonderful officers in the NAACP.
I thought a lot of them would go out and cause...
I would always follow the rule.
But anyway, I didn't think that...
All we wanted to be free like the other place of one.
And I just never did get in the way.
They couldn't sometimes try to talk me out of the wood.
They were well.
We had protests and they were saying,
you remember the old and protest we had.
Teogas.
We told all of us at all times...
We just had a rough time and don't they trying to get our freedom?
What was the protest all for?
What was that about?
That was most about the student, you know.
This is most about students having a chance.
There's so many...
I came to the mountains of the greenery and we carried in.
We carried in so many of the greenery that...
What was going on at all,
and not the fact that there's a student in the right neighborhood,
they didn't have...
In the workers there, they worked on the campus,
they kept all the workers.
They wouldn't get paid for what they should've been paid.
I just remember seeing them pecking over,
but I know they were five, five, three, or a new kid,
carried in.
I know them with a...
I can't name them now,
but I know they weren't paying the labor
what they were supposed to get.
That's one of them.
But it was five, I used to know them all,
but right now I'm kind of rushing.
But that's what it was all about.
What was the tear gas like?
What was it like to have that happen?
Well, it was really rough.
I mean, they tear gas, then tear gas.
I mean the stove, some of them were in the stove.
The tear gas I sold,
the man before the tear gas,
you see the student had a guy who had gotten a bad stove.
And the patrolmen and everything,
the student had to come around.
I was with that group of people when I was going Alcorn,
and you know, I'd be right,
like you're a survivor of the hooking horses.
Now I know how to go around,
and go around to pet and get to pet and stove.
And I really see her.
And one more was a person than me.
But I wanted to do,
with protesting around the back of the pet and stove,
around the village and brought them in.
And patromen, they got mad,
but I did all the students who got in there.
That's when they started throwing the tear gas.
And I had to lead those students back out.
What happened with the students when,
if they were protesting,
if somebody knew they were in the movement,
what would happen to the students?
I don't know if they had been able to kept them.
I don't know what would happen,
but it was,
take my trade at all,
and I used to hook my horse.
I used to ride from here,
old Alcorn in Moan,
and take my new job,
be a train.
But anyway, I knew how to do,
I knew who I would do,
hook my horse,
and I knew how to go around.
And then you get back to the,
the play where the students stayed.
And I led them,
George and Wogan,
and I lit those students back around,
with their fillet station
coming back around there,
seeing when the students got back to the dormitore,
they started shouting in the hall and then singing again.
And that made it to put crewman mad then.
And that's when they,
I was back on,
back on,
you know, by the pad and stove back with the movement.
And that was when they started throwing the tillgit,
they got mad and they went and they knew,
they didn't know how to do,
they got back,
but we had killed them back,
and I knew how to get back.
And then,
and they started tillgit.
They started tillgit,
and the stove never went.
And most people were going to strangle,
and they beat up,
I know they beat up two of my friends in one pre-jewel.
He was,
he was just sitting on some side of the car,
paired by a hit him,
beat him up and beat her,
but another,
there's a kid,
crumpled through the hallfield.
But anyway,
they tried to get
ever.
That's the month
with
Ruin
dolls,
Ruin dolls,
and I
caught ever.
The tillgit asked me,
but see, I had been used to tillgit asked.
I mean, I was in
silver,
and I thought I was taking my train in silver,
but anyway,
they just had to put their
battal on them,
no.
But anyway,
we bought,
they didn't,
they didn't hit ever.
But they beat all the rest of them,
and they said,
one of them said,
don't hit him.
Then I bought one side of them,
the rest of them,
the dolls,
and we don't know the other side of them,
but it was out of there.
Why do you think they didn't want to hit him?
I don't know.
I often don't want to,
but you know,
sometimes they don't hit a little,
sometimes they don't,
they don't hit a little,
you don't know what would happen.
I don't know what,
green-wide,
but I heard him say that.
Yeah.
And I had one side of them,
and Rubbin Dolls had,
the other side of them,
but anyway,
we got the elbows out of the wing,
and I went back and tried to hit,
those stranded women
who were, you know,
till their head,
they were a lot of them down,
get them a,
but anyway,
they beat up two people
that they had taken to a hospital.
One of them was Mr. Warnersfall,
right?
Yeah, he didn't want to,
uh,
he, that was June Warners,
Uncle.
He's Uncle?
Uh-huh.
Then Rubbin,
a,
a dramatic boy,
I'll forget his name,
not, but that was a preacher.
Okay.
He beat him up.
He was from Haddishburg?
Yeah, even from Haddishburg.
When they had the marches out at all corn,
you remember what year that was?
Hmm.
I was thinking,
I was trying to, uh,
well, that was 19,
there was six,
wasn't it?
66.
That's right.
Did you get,
you got arrested on one of those all corn marches, didn't you?
Did you get arrested?
Yeah, I got arrested.
I got arrested on the foot of the march.
You did have another one,
but the placement wall,
it was on the,
on the south side,
you're going through,
going through all the lawnmower,
you know, coming in.
No, that's the word you're supposed to be.
And the second time,
that was until,
until, until,
until we came in from the way.
But then we,
I was,
you know,
you arrested all of us and put us in jail.
And, uh,
were you worried about that?
Well, I was driving a school bus at that time.
That's time,
a wife there,
driving a school bus.
She had never been driving,
but she had been driving car all the time.
But she had never driven,
had never driven that big old bus.
But in any way,
she had to pick up children for me.
Of course,
I was in jail.
You know,
but anyway,
that's the time that risks us there.
But the time I was shooting by the tillgets,
ever the second time,
that,
that was the first time
and they put us in jail.
Throw all those in jail.
You know,
Did you stay in jail alone?
Just overnight.
Yeah.
You know,
they,
you had to have,
you know, something to bury you out of it, you know.
What was the, uh,
what were the mass meetings like?
The mass meetings were good,
a lot of things,
and clapping and going on.
And until, you know,
uh,
it'll get up until,
you know,
what we had to do,
what the mass meetings were being.
And,
and finally,
before we break up,
we,
we take a march around the town, you know.
We take,
we scroll the whole group
we're around,
and march on down,
uh,
town,
and then,
there's one time,
a text,
this is just one time,
you take some of them,
but they, most didn't,
uh,
they,
they pulled these thin balls
too much,
you know,
if we stay in line,
anybody get out of line?
They attempt one time,
but you know,
sometimes they stop
and say,
they have,
say,
we had a right to,
and prove death.
And,
some white was,
you know,
against the police, you know,
stopping this.
One, one time,
we had,
uh,
disturbing light,
they were the police,
but they assumed,
the left was going to make that march,
and,
but,
the march and,
it would,
more to call it,
and you're going to tip the night?
I would,
say, you are going to tip the night?
But in a way,
uh, we didn't have,
one incident,
and that's when I,
told him,
police kind of,
broke that up,
to some of the police,
it started.
You know,
uh,
I didn't try to stop the march,
or something,
or,
and chief,
you know,
told him,
let him march,
let him,
go on,
make that prove death.
Long as they didn't,
threw in the rocks,
or,
doing the thing too much,
you know,
to the souls of anything.
Here's some people marches there,
but, you know,
and then,
tap nothing,
then break it,
throw one or the nothing,
or close it,
and then,
if you experience suchettあー,
or you've never tried to do a part of it.
I do wish it could be the same.
Especially when a leader
in which you have done anything,
your brother orders a rally
or maybe he's done some lepass.
Uh,
all right.
Of course,
I feel that this ball–
what's the...
what was the boycott
about the poor Gibson Boycott?
It was about
and you know, you wouldn't pay the workers' power.
I was trying to think of all of them dreaming, and we had.
But I remember in any shop there was back there, but I know that the pay, I remember that, because we wouldn't get paid in many ways where we were shooting for a good pay.
And the working condition now, it was a lot of unright, that we wouldn't have it at that time.
We just, the house, the neighbors, the working house, the other things.
And the most was the pay.
Was it hard to organize the boycott?
Well, it was pretty hard because a lot of people were afraid.
The giant lot of pounds didn't let the children participate.
A lot of them didn't understand. A lot of them were just afraid to get in the bar.
That's the way it was, though, that was dedicated and new footage of all about it.
This is all right, but the pound most, you know, control the children is the most of a state on plantations like that.
And they had control over, you know, most majority of the people stayed on plantations at that time.
It got, you know, started, we got out there with participants, you know, quite naturally, the pound there.
Everyone stopped the children, called to move, lost their place, and then the other time, like that.
But that, that was the most of the field part.
What was, did your son participate in the school of desegregation?
He was young.
We had to control him.
He wanted to be, you know, that little group wanted to be just like Bruce Sheer.
He wanted to throw rocks at people, cars, and things like that.
And we just wanted him to do that.
We didn't let him do that.
We told him we had to land all that to him.
We had a rough time, you'd get them away from the other group.
But anyway, they broke that, that the group up was, that was the little group.
They called them the blackheads?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Rocked a brick there and people called and they like that, you know, had people's, or free it.
But they didn't blackhead drew.
Why would they, when they would throw rocks or something, why would they do that?
I don't know.
You know, a lot of people didn't participate, they were at the Civil Rights family, I don't know.
They had children.
It wasn't about the children, it wasn't about town, wasn't letting the children participate.
That was all about it.
Because, you know, that's what all of that started by, quite naturally, you know,
that they had to break up that before, never right.
I didn't, I nearly go along with that either.
What about, did they all, was it the same group that we do in South Japan?
Well, they, they, we say soon, broke up that blackhead group, you know.
That, that, that was the group that, you know, were throwing rocks at a car, the bank.
Did you see them?
Did, did you ever have to stand guard?
Did you ever have to protect your house or anything or anybody else?
No, no, I, no, I didn't have to never do that.
No.
Rev. Dawson, he had to have some protection.
Yeah, yeah.
And I don't know why I run them all and then had to have a ticket, but,
Roman, he wasn't, you know, he, he wasn't a dedicated, I remember Dorsey's wall.
When, when the school started desegregating, when they started having freedom of choice,
did your, did your children go to freedom of choice?
Well, my children, they went right along with y'all, you know, a lot of them were alone.
You was a little older than that, wasn't it?
A lot of them?
Yeah, a lot of them were sick to three.
Yeah, he, yeah, he, he, old knew.
Yeah.
You remember him, he was, yeah, he, old, much older than you.
But anyway.
Did he go over to PG?
Yeah.
What was his, what was his experience over at the white school?
Oh, really?
But he, he, I don't know, he must have been pretty small.
He, he, he passed out there.
Yeah.
I don't think about three of them, drag wheeled there the time.
Then he's clear.
I was trying to think, name, name, wasn't.
Hmm.
But he was one.
Yeah.
I know there were three of them.
And he was one, one of the three, who did drag wheeled there the year.
And he, with the voter registration, I know the voter registration started around, uh,
got very active after the voting rights act.
And, uh, by, like, middle of 1966, it was a black majority.
Was it hard to get people to run for office?
It wasn't so, it was, it was, it was at a place it was, was scared of time.
You know, it was hard to try to, I know we had to try to go out and try to find somebody
who was brave enough to run.
And, um, yeah, it was pretty rough to find somebody who no, no, no run.
And, uh, my, my, wherever the 19, 67, I believe, uh, when we first couldn't get about two or three,
we've got Mad Raw and, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, Mr. Ellis Collins.
And one of them was three.
Um, Miss Collins, uh, let's just say.
Yeah, Miss Collins.
Miss Collins, yeah.
But in any way, it was just hard to find somebody who run because I was, I was one,
going out through the county trying to find somebody who would be able to run.
And, then, I think it's, uh, if I lose my job, you got to give me a job.
And, yeah, I was, I was one who I tried to find somebody who can't do the run.
And, of course, I was on the, you know, the committee.
And, we had a rough time finding somebody who run.
We've got Mad Raw, she run.
You know, the, then I caught her and me was caught in it.
And my wife.
The day was one more or the person.
I got pictures of it back there somewhere.
But anyway, we did the fish.
And, uh, when your wife, when your wife got elected to the elected circuit court, right?
In 1971.
I just said no one.
But see, we had a hair lesson before then, didn't number three.
The first time we had, didn't by three black women.
That was a miss though.
Let's see, she run.
The Mad Raw was the one.
And then, what was this?
What was this?
Damn, the case still.
Damn, the case was on then. Damn, the case on.
We just had three street run.
I know three, three on.
The first time we ran in 1967, then by three people won.
How did you feel when Miss Jones got elected?
Well, I'm driving.
As I said, you know, the secret, the ten or the ten, was my friend.
And, uh, you had her right here.
Right there in the kitchen there.
I'm a wife.
So, it was no fear because they had, you know, the superintendent, those in the bank and everything.
I had plenty of help, but anyway, I wasn't afraid at all.
If we see she won.
Did it feel good to...
Yeah.
Were you in the circuit club?
Yeah, I felt good, but she, I felt good.
She, three or two years, you know.
What was the singing like in the movement?
The singing, the song?
Oh, yeah.
We should overcome, you know, whatever the song may be.
They've petbed that and them children were saying it, so I would do them.
And, uh, freedom to the song, that, saying that song too.
But in a way, we would have that ever to the, uh, to the night, ever once, every month,
every month, every day, first two of them, all had a movement.
Who was, uh, who was leading the song?
I'm trying to think about that.
Hmm.
I can't call a name, number.
Miss Crowder?
No, Crowder?
No.
I mean, this Crowder, she would reflect, among the place of one, you know, leading the
neighborhood with the young girl, that was trying to think her name.
She would, but Miss Crowder was with the group, the young, young group.
There are two groups, but singing.
But in a way, she was, she was one, Miss Crowder was one of them.
Did they have a youth choir?
Yeah, but that's, the youth choir, that's everyone I was trying to call the name, uh,
Dawg, baby, we call it Dawg.
Um, it wasn't one of the brands.
No, she was a, you know, what, uh, she out there, she was a, well, she could heal, I was
trying to think to do a name.
I probably know.
I should know.
We call it Dawg, I know, we call it Dawg.
She used to need them some.
Do you remember a white lawyer named Fred Berder?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Good boy.
He, one, was my lawyer when I got to play.
Okay.
Yeah, he, he, my lawyer, he, the one lawyer, doing a football play.
Good, yeah.
Um, can you tell us about our mark?
Yeah, I'm on, uh, the, our mark came out of the, the movement.
You know, we had to have news, by sheer, I had to have a seal to get our mark started.
Um, I'm a guy, I'm a shareholder, had to have a shareholder.
And we had, uh, I'm a guy, I'm a shareholder, I know, um, we were, the leading shareholder, we
were almost sure, didn't any rest of them.
Mr. Alexander Carlin, he, the trip around Pire, Sickle Lost, didn't know there was
a good, enough share to get this, two started.
Somehow we had a good minute share, and that's where you got started, but you know, you
know, I'm giving a share, we had to have a guy started.
In 19, 6, 19, it was 69.
I think it might have been 67.
67, but I thought yeah, you know.
What was the, what was the motivation?
Why did you all decide to organize the grocery store?
Whether we wanted to have a grocery store or own that, that's the way we cut all of
it.
I wanted to have a grocery store or own that, but the first chain we had, and on the way
we could get it, you know, by sheerholder, wasn't, wasn't, you know, I was able to know the
group of by, and have a store like that, we wanted, but in Covertish Stove, that was
wanted, because Madronium had a list of it on it.
But anyway, we wanted in Covertish Stove, and now that when the competition really started,
you know, in the community with the fights, so, we didn't done well, we were 25 dollars
for share, therefore, you know, we had so many 25 dollars shareholder, we didn't, I was
standing in shareholder, we didn't have, but, never seen, two, three or four, I was, you know,
rubbing, and rubbing, I took this as name, but anyway, he would top shareholder, and I think
Alexander Cotlin was in the second shareholder, and we were on third, we were on third, and we were on third,
and there was a, we had a choir, few, I think we had around about seven, seven-some shareholder,
but they were on the head, most of them had 25 dollars, most of them had 25 dollars,
and they only won share, and 25 dollars for share.
And what was your job with Armart?
My job, you know, was, I was on managed group, but I was on that, you know, management,
Armart, I was on the board.
Oh, we had a team on the board, I was just an Alexander Cotlin, and then preacher from what I was saying
with top shareholder, rubbing, he wasn't or was Lewis, but anyway, he, the top shareholder was preacher,
and from, he wasn't Rev. Dawson, no, he was from Jackson, I tried,
Reverend Smith, yeah, R.L.T. Smith, yeah.
He had a shop up in Jackson, didn't he?
Yeah, he had a store up there, I used to grow up there all the time, through his store, he had two stores up there,
they went on land street and went up there on the other street, I tried to sing.
So did he help you on how to run the store, did he help you figure out how to do it, how to put it together?
Yeah, he helped a lot about that, he really helped a lot of hard to grow about, you know, hard to get their staffs,
because we would have meeting every month, and don't do time, you come down there and check on them.
What time?
But we started, you know, we started paying off share, we paid share, 25 dollars of share, or shareholder meeting and share,
every year we paid off share, you know, really, some of us, like, Reverend Smith and,
and that's Colin, and we would never, we put our share right back in the store, and our share would, you know,
come, mother-ply.
But anyway, that's the way you got started, but, you know, shareholder meeting and the way,
did pretty well, we turned over, you know, a quarter million dollars a year,
but, you know, we had a lot of overhead, the thing that had paid off shareholder there, they, they, they want, they want, they pay every year, you know,
yeah, and, but we tried my wife and I, and, and, and, and, one other person tried to tell them, let the minister in there, let's go buy,
or, or, stole another community, or we had a chain of stone, but now everybody wanted money, don't know,
yeah, and then go for that, and see, see, we wanted to have a, stolen, and, and,
I mean, poor Gilsen, we might have had one somewhere else, somewhere else, that we, we were trying to get them,
get, to see, lead money in there, we're quite a few, I was trying to get them, do that, but, majority, you know,
all we were in, yeah.
What was, what was Charles' house like?
Charles, no one, he was, he was kind of a straightforward person, I, I, I, that one putting a little, I was with him,
but in this year, I believe in this year, yeah, yeah, and, he, and poor Gilsen, yeah,
and, said, right with him, but in a way, he, he, he was kind of straightforward person,
and, and he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, the person,
not on just me, me, placed in the living, the whole community living, they, they still living.
So, he, he, he put him, he was, he was really, he was really a good person, he was a good leader.
What was the, the lawsuit about Playborne hardware versus end of LACP?
That was a suit that brought against us, about the boycott.
You see, they brought that suit against us, of course.
They were claiming that we, the buyer and putting them boycott on, you know,
they cut down income or what's the other, they cut, yeah.
The profit?
The profit, cut the profit.
Never did suit us about it.
It had to go on to cope with it at the minute of time, but,
anyone who, he took a long time for us to the winters, we did winters.
And, we were in 1980, wasn't it?
82.
82?
Yeah.
Yeah, in 1982, when we won a suit.
What, your property was tied up for a while, wasn't it?
Yeah, my problem was tied up.
Did that make it more difficult to farm or anything?
It didn't make, it didn't make it difficult to farm because,
you know, as I said, you know, it had some white friends, you know,
the sea crease, and they had a haystown in the bank.
That's what I did, my work.
And, you know, I had others in the bank.
I had so many people on my side, they didn't, they didn't.
I could get anything I wanted.
I mean, they supported me.
They just said, I could get anything I wanted, you know,
but, you know, I just popped with Pima Bill.
That's it.
Pima Bill.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was, you know, I worked hard and I always was friendly with them and they were
there.
Some of them come out here and hunt on my plays and hunt with me and be with me.
That's friendship means a lot.
What do you want people to know about the Civil Rights Movement?
Yeah, I want them to know, you know, you know, how it brought us through.
And how it was before, before Civil Rights came in, there was something that, you know,
that we had hope, you know, as I told you before, that,
I was done in the 1930s, I was being early in the 1930s.
I always wanted to know John and ACP, you didn't know how to get in touch with because we
had really, the later part of the 1930s, I believe,
we got a really old thing like that, the real hell if we were going on in the world by the
Civil Rights, then we wanted John and that's when, you know, we really got interested in it.
But anyway, we all, we went on John and, when we had a chain,
but it would take chance to John.
You just, you just couldn't let it be known that you were the car holder for the end of
this machine. And you couldn't care it only because you didn't know whether you
would be held up with officer or not because you might read that what happened to
the car, cared and put right in the trunk of your son, that time,
the, the, the, the, on that boy got killed, I believe he would have killed that boy
by having a car or end up they seem to be caught.
And that, you know, had a lot of fear on us, but, you know, when we got a car or
a car or anything like that, a lot of, we wouldn't, we wouldn't, we wouldn't
have caught up, we would have put them up, but we, we always would have had a car.
So, we were watching enough and glad, you know, we could get, you know, what
we were going on and put something about our right, you know, we, we really
know, knew what, I put a goal and, and the organization always told us,
you know, it's something about freedom, we wanted to be free and everything,
but we couldn't, this would be open, we had to be, you know,
do it on the ground, yeah, we, I come, my first heart, I got the name,
coming down the street, coming down the street, the thing here you caught,
and I had the heart and the car, the first car, we got, you know, a scared
of the kid on, a scared of having a house, we burned, we burned, we burned the first car,
we, we, we, we, we, we got, we, we kept, we, we weren't
to burn that car, but we put, scared us, you know, what happened and
pulled them when, when they caught that boy with that car, you know, and that
made us afraid to kill that car on, you know, but he didn't stop you from getting it?
No, he didn't stop him, he didn't stop him, he couldn't, he didn't stop me from
going to the meat, you know, because we, it was a preacher, Ramon,
and he taught us, well, we taught us, what time we spoke to go, you need,
you had it, always be at our church, that church, I told you, right across the
Emonyo, you know, make sure to be on the side of it, and after one car.
So the street would be full, and you know, he'd buy a shopping, he'd buy a
shopping, and, and those days, I think, when I first got my car, I was trying
to think what it would would work, but then we didn't, at that time, I, we,
I had no bone meal car, truck or nothing, we were going town and waving, then,
but anyway, we waited time to go down into the street on the, just by one
hour, and it never would be over 10 or 12 of meat, when they said,
in that, that's, that's when we would get to court, you know, till, you know,
they have a little meat and child, but I write names, I hope, but I hope,
I'm never tired, but I was in, I was, you know, in, more, I'm trying to
think about, do it, study, I thought, or, for the truth, something like that,
it's really, back then, but anyway, that's the way it was, in those days,
I lived through it, but somehow, I just never worked here for, I don't know
and rewind it, it is a lot of, no, my friend, the other time it was scared,
but I don't know, I don't know if I wouldn't give it in, but anyway, I guess
I don't know if you're interested in the
own contents of my family.
You have a large family in the head,
the log and job and everything.
In the plantation, we, the whole family,
picked cotton on planet.
And those people, they don't own a land
and they killed a lot of people from my family
or something because we were working,
we were logging and farming.
People have a spec for you?
Yeah, we would pick cotton on our mind
and be cotton planted in big plantation.
You know, we would three of us
would pick well over 200 pounds of them.
And they were, had a group here.
Big found that the young group here,
but be here on the farm, you can't farm on here.
But the older group, my age,
and older, older, I think,
and I never see them.
Four, four, four of us would go out picking cotton.
We could pick, we could pick a big
a big day in a big plantation where all they
could.
I guess by the big family and reenwish,
had a pretty good time, which then,
on the stroke keepers of hooting on,
the white rays, I said that time.
We had a lot of respect for us,
and we had a lot of respect for them
because we wanted jobs.
And then we got some jobs.
Yeah, we didn't pay much.
So thank you so much.
You're round nine.
Yeah, round nine.
It's been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.